some of us in this room are extremely
lucky to be the byproduct of an
incredible mother and when you are the
byproduct of an incredible mother you
are really Unstoppable and so like
nothing scares me I think I can do
everything and she's you know the beacon
and Seed of everything that has worked
for me in my life and so the reason if
some of you have seen my social media
the reason I put up the number five is
that's a little bit of a head nod to the
person that crafted me and that's my mom
my mom built huge self-esteem in me and
I feel like the biggest reason I am who
I am today to everybody is because I
feel so guilty and so grateful for what
she did for me that I want to do it for
everybody else which is guess what you
suck at a ton of good so does
everybody else you're also probably
pretty radical nothing try as many
things as possible until you figure out
where your rad at and you like and go
and do that for the rest of your life
and stop giving about everybody else